I was originally going to talk about
traffic management in general and then
when I looked at the different talks
which were presenting are being
presented I changed my mind and i'll
talk about i make sort of what the
startup companies called a
forward-looking talks so this is a
forward-looking talk on how instead of
playing nashit cetera why don't we just
increase the throughput capability of
the regular roads we have right and so
the technology of connected vehicles
allows you to dramatically increase the
capacity of the roads and so that's what
I want to talk about whoops
thing
okay so it has to do with intersections
and so let's just keep
so intersections of what controls the
traffic in the urban streets right and
in turn the traffic is controlled by the
way the red yellow green lights are
programmed to react and so
my previous hawk was going to be how you
should design that the control of the
red yellow green lights and ninety
percent of the roads or the signals in
the united states that controlled by so
called fixed time controls so it goes
from red yellow green or the different
phases in a fixed pattern so it's an
open-loop periodic sequence and there's
a lot of theory about how you should do
that ten percent do adaptive control so
they take actual measurements around the
intersections from sensors or maybe GPS
traces and then adaptively control the
red yellow green so I'm not going to
talk about that at all and let me talk
about something called the intersection
capacity so the intersection capacity is
defined in the following way and you can
measure it so I is a movement so
typically from each direction you have
three movements red I mean left straight
and right so if you have a four
intersections you have 12 movements in
all and G sub I so capital T is the
cycle time when the whole thing will
repeat so maybe two minutes typically or
between one and two minutes G sub I is
the amount of green time that is devoted
to movement number I rights of the 12
movements there's 12 of these G sub i's
SFI is a so called saturation flow rate
for that movement that is to say if that
movement had an infinite queue and
that's staying green all the time what
is the number of vehicles that would go
through right in that particular
movement so the capacity of the
intersection is the saturation rate of
that in terms of that movement
multiplied by the fraction of time that
that movement is getting green green
right so that's the capacity of the free
right typically the saturation flow rate
per Lane is / movement is between 1200
and 1900 vehicles per hour so that's the
typical things that you can go out and
measure and that's what you'd get
so let's take this particular standard
intersection and instead of considering
12 moves I'm going to ignore the right
turn because the right turn you can do
it anytime you have to wait for a green
so from each direction you have two
movements a through movement and the
left movement so you have eight and all
so you have eight movements in all and
suppose the the capacity of the road
leading to that is about 1900 equals per
hour so the total available traffic
coming into the intersection is about
1900 times eight however ate all these
eight movements cannot go through the
intersection at the same time right
obviously and so what you're permitted
for non interference is only two
movements at a time wait so you can see
the good north south and south mode or
both ty steak left the one goes through
and left so only two movements are
permitted at a time so the dissection
capacity if the saturation flow rate for
each of those is 1900 the intersection
capacity is 3800 the capacity of the
roads leading to the network is four
times as much so the intersection
capacity / lane capacity is one-fourth
so the intersection is the main
bottleneck in urban roads right and if
you dig deeper the main bottleneck is
the saturation flow rate for that
particular intersection that right so
the proposal I'll make is to increase
that saturation flow rate not to change
anything else not to change the signals
etc but see how to do that
so here's an example empirical data from
some intersection in Los Angeles the
speed limit on that road is 50 miles per
hour and so I'm looking at one
particular movement and you see the
first vehicle which leaves after the
green starts it takes three and a half
seconds or 3.4 seconds before it reacts
to that green and starts moving the next
15 point etc and the time before the
green phase ends of the phase in this
particular case is 50 seconds long so it
started at 3.4 after the phase then that
it left at so much time so the amount of
time it stood there was three point 88
and then it keeps decreasing the speed
as what it has it entered the
intersection or its first 1738 and get
the last one was really fast 73 so the
average speed with 12 vehicles is about
42 miles per hour when you just do this
average and the equals 125 enter in 14
and a half seconds so the Emperor
empirical saturation rate which is the
first guys is 3600 / this so it's twelve
hundred and seventy two vehicles per
hour notice the vehicles 56 attacks are
traveling much faster speed so if you
could move all these guys together at
the higher speed you'd have a much
bigger saturation flow rating right so
that's the proposal
so the tow vehicles together moved as a
train as a platoon at 45 miles per hour
with a time had way between pickles of
point 75 seconds the saturation flow
rates would be that would be 4,800
equals per hour instead of the 1200 you
might say point 75 is too aggressive so
let's make it one point two seconds in
which case the saturation flow rate
would be 3,000 vehicles per hour which
is still two and a half times what you
observe so it's about that much right
note that the head lay between in the
previous example within legal seven and
eight was already point seven seconds
and when even saying point 75 or 1.2 so
the question is can we move all these
cars together right so let's define the
platoon capacity of an intersection
instead of the current thing that we can
measure and we could supposedly get in a
speed limit of 30 miles per hour which
is that much and a space had way of 43
feet between vehicles you'd get a
saturated protune saturation weight of
3,600 or 3,000 vehicles per hour which
is between 1.7 and 2.3 times more than
you can so that you could increase in
principle you could increase the
throughput by that sort of factor right
so there are two issues can this be done
what is the technology and number two if
you did that what will happen in terms
of queues and delays etc ok so that's
the story so first let me see if this
can be done so here our experiments this
is an experiment in the Netherlands of a
six-car platoon so the way they have not
in order to do that you have to know
when the other guys leaving all right I
mean that's the part you don't wait for
him to leave and then you say oh I
should move and I should move so they
should move together so that we need
some communication or some automatic way
in which you'd keep the distance with
the car from so this is sickkk a platoon
and they implement this because they
each have simply an adaptive cruise
control which not many cars have
together with the Wi-Fi to give you some
idea about when the vehicle is leaving
and what they find is they can get the
saturation a space a time headway of
point 75 seconds so they can reach 4800
vehicles per hour yeah they know that
the green isn't going to turn to read by
the time the last vehicle of the platoon
goes through come to that so at this
point we're not worrying about those
practical questions so that those
questions will certainly have to be
answered and some of the other the
intersection would have to signal break
up the platoon or terminated at this
point right so simply doing a proof of
concept here okay so so that's the the
speed following of these and so it's
moving quad up and down but this platoon
is able to keep track of the previous
week oh this is a four-car platoon done
here in Richmond and so this is much
more aggressive they're doing this and
the thing is following and so it has
point 666 second headway at 60 miles per
hour so that can give you 50 100
vehicles per hour of through portal so
let's put a moment suppose that we can
do that we can arrange things so
everybody who is standing in front
queued up in front of the light is
adaptive cruise control and their head
lazer x are set to be 1.2 seconds or one
second more aggressively point seven
seconds we won't worry about the
termination of this platoon when when
the green light would be over so there's
a pure productivity increase right just
from the way in which those cars are
able to hear and it increases the
saturation somewhere between 70 and two
hundred fifty percent productivity
increase is possible so what can you use
it for well you can use it for
increasing the throughput so providing
supporting lot more demand on that order
higher demand with no changes in
infrastructure other than the changes
acquire
communication and control of this
platooning business right the adaptive
cruise control part is already there so
we don't need to worry about we do have
to worry about the length of the platoon
and how many vehicles can go in and when
you can you shut them so that's one way
you can increase it by increasing
throughput there's a perhaps a more
interesting use of it which is you can
reduce the queue lengths and the delay
by reducing the cycle time the queues
form because of the red right during the
red the queues just how many vehicle
just arrived and stock up so if instead
of having green for 30 seconds in red
for 30 seconds I could reduce them green
for 15 and red for 15 and green for 15
and Redford 15 then your queue build-up
will be reduced by a factor of 2 roughly
right why don't we do that the reason we
don't do that is because whenever you
change this face green safety requires a
three second of all red so you don't
have just green now and then green this
way you have a red period so if you
reduce that taco town you pay a penalty
right but if I have so much productivity
increases maybe I can pay that penalty
and reduce the
so let's see if they can provide some
theoretical support for these
conjectures so here's our network I
converted into a queuing network so so
each movement is index I so X is the
number of vehicles I mean that I mean
each movement is I and Excise number of
vehicles who are stuck or or chewed up
when they get a green they arrive at a
sub I and they leave at the rate be sub
I and then they will turn depending upon
some rotting probabilities so BJ comes
out then our ji goes to movement I and
that's the travel time that it takes
since once you get a network like that
now the service rate of the ice cube is
see I of T that's the amount that's the
saturation flow rate multiplied by the
average green duration so that's see I
of T so it'll be periodic with period t
so it's a SAT right when the light is
green and see I of T is zero when it's
ready so it's a queuing system which
gets periodic service and non service
and service and non service and service
and lawn service X I of these a queue
length departure rate arrival so
you can write down the mall dynamics
which is simply the rate of cube growth
is the arrivals minus the departures the
arrivals is the external arrivals plus
the arrivals which come from the other
intersections and the travel time so
this guy comes from intersection j2 link
number I that's the travel time that's
the fraction which arrives and the
departure rate if there is a cue the
departure rate be proportional to the
service rate if there is the ques-
that's not possible and when the Q is
zero the service rate is anywhere
between zero and the full service rate
right so this is non-linear equation and
inclusion but anyway the end story is
that there is a unique solution to this
system differential equations and now
let's think about with little
parameterize is because I want to change
the service rate either double it or
triple it or fifty percent more and we
take the input parameters of system to
be the external exogenously rival raise
the service race and the initial state
and if you look at that system and you
look scared a little bit it turns out to
be positively homogeneous of degree 1 so
that means that if i increase the that X
of T a of arrivals skews departures if
that's the solution of that system and c
is a factor productivity increases then
c time to XC x AC times b is a solution
for that system so that means that if i
increase the service rate through the
saturation flow rate by fifty percent
then this thing can increase the
throughput by fifty percent which
intuitively is very very clear what
happens to the queue lengths I'm not
changing the cycle time so the queue
length we can see will increase by
exactly the same amount so if I mean if
I'm doubling the throughput so twice as
much demand and go through but I'm not
changing the cycle time then my cues
will be double
because twice as many vehicles arrive
during the red what about the delay
right so I mean this queue length growth
may pause the problem he caught the
problem but you run into the previous
intersection right but what about the
delay assuming that that was not a
problem the average delay is the average
queue length divided by the average
arrival rate the average queue length is
doubled the average arrival rate is
doubled so the average delays unchanged
so if you could accommodate all that
traffic you could send twice as much
traffic through you have twice as big
cues but you're not spending more time
in the queue because you'll be moving
through faster so the delay gets
unchanged but and that's very obvious
over here so this is the arrival rate
and the departure rate when C equal to 1
this is the arrival rate once when you
double the demand and the departure rate
when you develop the man and you see
that the delay between the ants vehicle
and the first instance is the same as
the two and three equal in the second
instance so delay is going to stay the
same but few lengths may be too large so
can I trade off some of the productivity
increases by reducing the cycle time
speeding that up and reducing the delay
so what should you we had the time t
supposing I speed up the time so just
which is essentially I'm making the
system run faster and you'll find that i
can if i increase my cap at my
throughput by a factor of C but I don't
increase my demand by the same factor
but I speed everything up then you find
that the queue length decreases by the
same amount so i could leave everything
the same double my saturation flow rate
decrease my cycle time by 50% don't
increase the traffic then everywhere
will go through with the queue size will
be decreased by 50% the delay will be
decreased by fifty fifty percent so the
end result is that this productivity
increase you can share in increase
demand and reduce delay by increasing
the cycle time so if i 100% possibility
of increase i can share it between fifty
percent increase demand plus a reduction
in the delay
so that is the bonus you get from this
thing this is an analysis of simulation
of that in the same network that Alex
discuss so let's skip through that and
it shows the simulation shows exactly
the kind of prediction that you expect
and you should following conclusion for
tuning technology can dramatically
increase the capacity of the
intersections and therefore which you
can now share between increasing the
demand increasing traffic or decreasing
queues and delays there are the partial
safety benefits because it's moving in a
platoon you reduce rear-end crashes a
lot of the accidents on intersections
are real in crashes but there'll be a
need to design the real-time
communication of control protocols of
platoons at the intersection primarily
having to do with deciding how large
your platoon you want to permit and so
you have to signal that card number 13
or car number 10 or car number 12 is the
last thing you should permit that
requires the communication among
vehicles but it seems to need possible
that just with adaptive cruise control
without such communication if you can
signal that you should stop following
that vehicle or if you say it's the
responsibility of the driver to obey the
red light right then that platoon is
automatically broken right when there is
the drivers time to come all right so
I'm not automating the whole thing is
just making sure that if you are at the
intersection and you push you adaptive
cruise control and you say i want to
point seven second gap that's fine or
1.2 second gap but when it turns red you
better not go after that alright so
that's would be a very cheap
introduction of this technology secondly
one of the last point is that in the
case of adaptive cruise control you
don't need all the vehicles to be like
that so the first three may be adaptive
cruise control and
to maybe just the regular cars and the
next one is adaptive cruise control so
it will follow the regular car in front
so you have a proportional increase
which will be in proportion to the
penetration of that the cruise control
technology that people are using right
yeah one of the question of the same
level of detail that you address right
now do you allow the platoon sorry sort
themselves at every intersection is it
because otherwise you have to plan your
route in the beginning enjoy the flute
tune that's going to do exactly the same
thing at all the intersections an
exponentially small fraction right so
here I'm saying I'm not going to the
protruding will only work to cross the
intersection after that you're on your
own right because notice that the
capacity of the roads is four times the
capacity of the intersection so it's the
intersection which is the bottleneck so
it's in at the intersection that I want
V equals to not to have like a spring
one goes and then the next one goes and
the third one gets impatient and moves
faster and faster right so the only use
only use of this is at the intersection
there could be an additional benefit if
you keep that platoon and it goes
through so then you have an extra
benefit from other reasons for example
if the lights are such that they are
synchronized so that you go you'll get a
green wave and if it's a platoon then
everybody will go to the green way
better but this story doesn't have those
additional benefits yeah yeahs shows me
is just really it's a very less point
you made which is
most of the loss is in coming to a halt
and then reacceleration instant the loss
of the loss of the capacity of an
intersection there's some physical loss
because you have a factor of two at the
intersection of actually a vector for
and you could do better if the cars
would arrive at the intersection still
going 30 miles per hour yet so so that
would be that would be this this what is
called offsets designing of offsets so
that the travel time through the
intersection exactly matches the offset
between the green phases so then you
don't stop you are a pulse of traffic
wait we've got that's right that's it's
called the Green Wave so your your
comment enter green red right and if
there was some way to tell drivers that
this is coming they would be
incentivized even if they have none of
this technology to ya directly answer
that point this type of BMW came rather
than you know the San Jose publishes the
traffic light should use you can get yes
so if you have a traffic lecture you
were still at San Jose what being look
you wanted was to how far north awful
feeling really in addition to this of
course so you sort of know that that
light is don't contain even though your
screen but have you get there right
don't stop
it is actually translate that's what he
wanted to do dig up one of the major
problems for that is this clock
synchronization yes when it's automating
like this it really went on about this
night completely appreciate it but
that's the other thing but but you know
if you have a should use the published
salaries releasing but mind you this
benefit of doubling the troop would has
nothing to do this on top of all of
those right i mean this gives you a
hundred percent increase in the in the
road traffic that you can tolerate those
are all bonus ting number one number two
they require a lot more infrastructure
development and calculation and and this
depending on the speed etc etc you'll
have to change the way the offsets are
synchronized and you need the
intersection to be able to signal to the
individual vehicles that the car the
light is going to turn red in three
seconds two seconds whatever it is so
this is a very low-tech solution which
only requires adaptive cruise control
and the drivers to obey the red green
light right
buying behavior the driver is slow on
the uptake and starting at the
intersection or somebody changes lanes
or bicycle is involved how could all of
those real life variations see what I'm
proposing right I'm saying you are at
the intersection there's no bicycle and
you are responsible for safety it's the
only thing I'm saying is that you push
you adaptive cruise control you which
are now is coming for stop go traffic
you press it it gives you some amount of
freedom whether you want it to be
aggressive so then you say point six
seconds or you want to be non aggressive
you put one point five seconds the the
person behind you has an adaptive
control but it doesn't want to use it so
he's just going to drive as he regularly
drives right but because you have
pressed that the the time had way
between you and the vehicle in front is
reduced so you would get through the two
of you will get through much faster than
if you were driving the way you're
driving right would take just much less
time and that is the major bottleneck at
the intersection
yeah so this reminds me one thing so
some people really might do remember
this better than me but my understanding
was like when TCP transmission control
protocol is changed in the 80s it's
partly because internet Reuters were
essentially merging together IP headers
and then it's called like a collective
synchronization throughout the system
crashes and that's why the rules changes
additive increase motzkin to decrease
rule now in this example you're
essentially synchronizing cars together
so you can imagine sitting over your
story for a single Junction and if you
had several junctions to connect it
together you could end up causing a
synchronization here then reasons the
next Junction synchronizes the cars that
resent these batteries situations where
in a network situation can be very
careful about the green eyes give the
three different junctures making signify
sections and each instability yes so I'm
decoupling those completely right I'm
saying that that the green time yes I
understand what you mean so here I'm not
changing the signals at all so the green
times are staying the same right as a
result you can have greater throughput
of traffic which could lead to large
accuse and will lead to large accuse but
you don't want to permit that because
that will lead to a saturation the link
and the upstream thing will get
congested so we're going to say okay we
have this possibility of doubling but
what i'm going to do i'm just going to
reduce my cycle time by twenty percent
so that will reduce the queues by twenty
percent you shouldn't admit twice as
much traffic I mean that's a bigger
issue right about how much traffic you
are willing to accept so that's a larger
issue of congestive control but I don't
see the synchronization problem as
propagating because I'm not trying to
control the individual lights right and
so I'm not going to there's no feedback
as such
well the implementation the Green Wave
is is just the way it is done now right
the only thing it requires is what is
the travel time between across the link
so that doesn't change I'm not saying
people should go faster on the roads and
just think they should go fast they're
not even going faster they should go
more quickly I mean don't leave don't
sip your coffee or read achiever you
know respond to your cell phone while
you're waiting at the intersection but
just react the way you ought to react
right yeah just one more thing and then
which is a so this is the way in which
congestion is growing right and just to
say we talk about freeway but sixty
percent of congestion occurs inside in
the city streets but there's a more
troubling aspect to me which is now 527
cities are have more than 1 million
population and the car ownership is
growing much faster than population
ownership so in 2014 about 83 million
cars were sold and in 20 80 and expect
to set 100 million in terms of
greenhouse gases in the US translation
accounts for twenty-six percent around
the world it's fourteen percent but this
massive increase in population so it's
possible to accommodate that by this
kind of technology but their side
effects which are far worse right which
is the emissions from these things and
so we need also to worry about the kinds
of things that biology is talking about
right getting people on to mass transit
or electrifying all of this stuff but
that will lead to pollution coming from
the electricity sector unless we move to
renewable so there's a so each of these
problems is buried in a bigger problem
right there
I'm done thanks
moreover the effect would be even most
congested big region where you may think
i'm downtown Austin where its peak
travel times to me 62 the same like
three times to make little to move to
the next time yeah no no uh-huh right
there's no avoidance of that right so
what is happening in downtown Austin is
your links are getting saturated so that
even when I have a green I cannot move
because the the there is no place to
move to right so that's an
oversaturation condition so that kind of
set condition whether you are moving
they have a platooning or no platooning
doesn't matter nobody can move because
I'm thinking once to for everyone goes
down yes because they're saturated no no
no I'm not it's a saturation effect is
the reason nobody can move is it's it
happens 302 on Oxford the link is very
small also get saturated and you get a
green but doesn't help you because that
link is already saturated now it could
be so so the particular things you
should teach to you should treat short
links together as one link and so those
lies should be just run together all
right so just make it into a long link
and then some of the some of the
problems are liberated
yeah and there's data that you are shown
in the slide eight or so like the speed
of the cars yes slow second car is
little passionate children it was only
the past three four cars as low yes and
presumably that's because this the red
light is a sudden like us yes so if they
are prime double drat sure those are all
things so that's it there's a reaction
time which may be I mean varies a lot
can be as much as a 100 milliseconds or
longer you saw in their those a few
seconds in that particular example so so
so you can you can do that in two ways
either you have a countdown timer which
says in China is everywhere for me yeah
yes in india or here we see you can see
the pedestrian crosswalk and you use
that to say when the thing is that so
definitely having a countdown timer so
again a low-tech solution which says
okay i'll be ready to start are you
getting a more fancies thing right which
tells you like the BMW story it tells
you that the light is going to turn
green in three seconds five seconds two
seconds whatever then that could be as
part of your leader of the platoon will
just automatically get thing moving so
you'd shave off a few seconds there
right to the point made in the last
slide besides electrification
transportation if travelers cars and
also it's sharing is very close take off
what you mean sharing right or you mean
sharing like cars so I'm little I don't
worry I don't drive more than say
flowers for neighbors yeah so if I
the car but whenever I need a car they
will be a driver sitar that transpire
should structure it depends on it
depends so if you're saying that
somebody will drive your car instead so
the car ownership will be less but if
the demand is not going to change so
same number vehicles are traveling the
road except it's your vehicle coming
twice so that doesn't change anything
right now you can go one step further
and say well we're going to because the
the fewer cars parked that will provide
you with savings yes they'll provide you
some savings all right but that's not
going to reduce the trans patient demand
and that's the same story with its uber
and all the cars are uber now if it's
automated vehicles I don't see how that
is going to reduce unless you say we're
going to pack people you know five
people per vehicle that I agree that
will reduce the transportation three
between these watch my station since all
automated possibly possibly
so I'm promoting sort of low-tech
solutions to a problem which seemed to
me that one can try right in saturday or
whatever some area as the acc cars are I
mean meant all the high-end cars have a
cc in their thing and the beak of
manufacturers are getting a lot more
aggressive by allowing it didn't stop
and go traffic so you can leave it on
acc and stop and we'll just move as the
car in front of you moves but I'm
worried about the the thing that if you
make it easier now you just grow the
demand will grow right that's that's the
other part of the story